bokassa renversé il est en france depuis
quelques minutes
nucléaire des fissures dans les
centrales françaises pas de danger
affirme andré giraud andré bergeron à
matignon la cinquième semaine de congés
c'est pour bientôt
mais là messieurs bonsoir il n'ya plus
d'empyr centrafricain il n'ya plus
d'empereur il n'y a plus de bokassa 1er
le dictateur de bangui a été limogé
cette nuit c'est en libye qu'il a appris
et sa déchéance
et c'est donc là que provisoirement il
trouvé refuge aux côtés d'un autre tir
en exil et idi amin dada
vous y trouvez reçu jusqu'à l'instant je
viens d'apprendre que l'avion du
président donc bokassa tenterait
d'atterrir en france tenterait car les
choses ne sont pas faciles
le groupe français aurait donné des
ordres pour que ça caravelle
n'atterrisse ni à orly ni à roissy
et il semble que son avion se dirige
maintenant vers la base militaire
d'evreux donc visiblement vous ne voyez
le goal man français ne souhaitent pas
avoir la présence de l'ancien dictateur
centrafricain et c'est l'ancien
président de la république
centrafricaine chasser il y à 13 ans par
bokassa qui est redevenu d'ailleurs
depuis peu son conseiller privé qui l'a
renversé cette nuit s'il s'appelle david
dacko il a 49 ans il connaît lui déjà le
chemin des lycées en effet voici le
président david dacko en janvier 1965 à
sa sortie de l'elysée
après des entretiens avec le général de
gaulle derrière monsieur da cau on
reconnaît monsieur foccart alors
conseiller à l'elysée monsieur da cau
confier ses préoccupations de l'époque
aux journalistes
cette présidentielle est l'objet des
entretiens avec général des mourides
il n'y avait pas de problème puisque
tous les problèmes ont été réglés à
l'échelon ministériel mais nous avons eu
une discussion d'ordre général sur la
politique franco centrafricaine
politique africaine et politique
international puis c'est tout vous
n'allez pas parler 400 après monsieur
bako est à nouveau au pouvoir il avait
été le premier président de la
république sans d'articles kane après
l'indépendance en 1960
c'est en raison de sa politique
économique et notamment des mesures
d'austérité impopulaires prises pour
assainir l'économie du pays qui avait
été renversée par le colonel bokassa
après quelques années de prison et
d'exil monsieur da cau était revenu en
grâce auprès de bokassa depuis trois ans
il était le conseiller est notamment
financier de l'ex-empereur bokassa
entre temps j'apprends à l'instant que
l'expérience d'un bokassa atterri il ya
10 minutes de cela à la base militaire
d'evreux semble qu'ils tentent de
rejoindre son épouse l'ex impératrice
catherine qui ne se trouve pas très loin
d'ici
a mantes la jolie voilà maintenant pour
le président da cau le prix dans la co
qui a derrière lui une carrière
politique plutôt aux sinueuses
je pense qu'il faudrait maintenant
s'attacher au pas de celui qui l'a
renversé sans effusion de sang jean
bedel bokassa alors plus qu'un long
discours je crois bien que cette
séquence illustre bien la personnalité
de l'ex empereur
nous sommes en plein conseil des
ministres
dans le cadre de notre système de
travail normal nous éprouvons
aujourd'hui la joie de recevoir ici dans
cette modeste salle de conseil des
ministres de la cour de bérigaud nos
amis de l'union soviétique
je crois que je vais vraisemblablement
recevoir ici de petits présents ce qui
permettra à l'antenne de d'apprécier nos
rapports avec nos amis de l'union
soviétique de la france nous tous les
pays du monde
notre principe ici est un principe de jo
creusot avec et jours ce qui signifie
l'homme reste l'homme et l'homme est
l'équivalent de l'homme au nom de leur
équipe
nous devrions travailler
est ce le ton se veut national pour moi
c'est que nous avons fait nos à notre
pays un petit village de fally fait bien
le palais mais si vous faites le saut
parfait nationale
autre séquence choc qui restera je crois
dans l'oeil et la mémoire de tous les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 le
couronnement fastueux et napoléonien de
l'ancien sous-officier de l'armée
française le cap décembre 1977 journée
universellement historique journée qui
verra se dérouler un événement sans
précédent dans les annales de l'afrique
centrale à savoir le couronnement de sa
majesté bokassa 1er empereur de
centrafrique
il était déjà maréchal secrétaire
général du parti unique il était
président à vie ce 4 décembre 1977 jean
bedel bokassa devient bokassa 1er ultime
péripétie d'une carrière politique fort
mouvementée peut-être même peut-il
remonter à son enfance pour comprendre
cet homme qui allait faire sourire le
monde entier avant daury fier l'afrique
le futur empereur étaient devenus
orphelins à 6 ans après que son père
était et bastonnés à mort et que sa mère
se suicider très vite à l'âge de 18 ans
il choisit la carrière militaire et
s'engage dans l'armée française la
seconde guerre mondiale l'indochine
allait nous permet de glaner de
nombreuses décorations et d'en sortir en
1962 avec le grade de capitaine dans la
nuit du 31 décembre 65
il passe à l'action il renverse son
cousin david dacko celui là même qui l'a
renversé hier soir dès lors jean bedel
bokassa à les multiplier les contacts
avec la france son pays d'adoption
disait-il avec le général de gaulle en
particulier qu'il appelait papa
mais c'est aussi à cette époque que sa
mégalomanie allait se révéler au grand
jour avec une série d'incidents
sanglants
ce sont d'abord les bastonnades de
juillet 72 le maréchal président conduit
lui-même un détachement de soldats armés
de matraques pour corriger les voleurs
détenus dans cette prison
bilan 3 morts et 42 blessés on cesse
alors de sourire jean-bedel bokassa
devient peu à peu l'un des dictateurs
les plus tyranniques et les plus
sanglants du continent africain mais il
faudra attendre avril dernier pour
mesurer l'ampleur ou fierté parmi ces
enfants qui chantent le nom de leur
empereur il allait y en avoir une
centaine d' assassiner pour avoir refusé
de porter lui une commission denquête
recomposée d'africains à les confirmer
cette pratique systématique de la
torture était décriée dans le monde
entier et en 1917 lorsque jean pierre
elkabbach à médium elle l'avait
rencontré il lui avait posé la question
de ces bastonnades et de ses oreilles
tout fait dans mon cas centrafricain
écoutez plutôt la réponse de l'empereur
aujourd'hui est le cas des oreilles
coupées il n'y a eu qu'un seul cas parce
qu'il s'agissait d'une bande de voleurs
ils étaient 47
ils étaient organisés ils étaient armés
ils avaient dévalisé le les
centrafricains de pleine journée ça
profite qu'à et les étrangers de plein
jour c'est pour cette raison que en une
seule fois
j'ai donné cette leçon mais après j'ai
réglé les mesures ça n'existe plus mais
ne se fait plus ça ne se fait plus ça ne
se fera plus ça ne se fera plus du tout
c'est un engagement que l'empereur
c'était un engagement que j'ai pris et
puis un engagement qui est écrit il ya
une autre menace qui le guident et pas
seulement parce qu'il ya le couronnement
dans quelques temps non du tout du tout
non je vous dis cela fait de la est
coupée c'est manifester le jour où il ya
eu des problèmes qui étaient posées
bastonnade
c'est la même chose et les s'était
accompagnée de c'était un cas c'est à
dire le même joug il ya eu ces mêmes qui
ont eu les joies et coupés ont été
d'abord barton et ça c'est sûr avant
d'avoir un jour la coupe et on a vu ce
qu'il en était donc quelques mois après
avec le massacre de plus d'une centaine
d'écoliers et d'adolescents dès midi
david dacko lançait un appel à la nation
centrafricaine notre pays s'effondre
dit-il le régime de bokassa s'est
décomposé il vous suce est comme une
sangsue en un mot il n'y a plus d'état a
conclu nouveau président
réaction par il envoie aux premières
heures de la matinée de deux compagnies
françaises tout d'abord stationnés au
stade tchad puis une troisième au gabon
pour éviter tout risque de troubles à
bangui
on voit qu'à regretter ange patassé
ancien premier ministre de bokassa il a
même exigé le retrait des troupes
françaises mais pour robert galley le
ministre de la coopération il ne s'agit
que d'une aide toute provisoire au
nouveau régime que tout
toutes les raisons compte tenu de sa
personnalité
compte tenu du fait que le président da
cau avait été en 1960 élu régulièrement
président de la république
centrafricaine au suffrage universel
qu'il avait exercé le pouvoir dans des
conditions tout à fait convenable
pendant cinq années
nous avions tout lieu de faire confiance
à sa personnalité
donc il vous est demandé d'envoyer des
troupes mais les craintes sont quelle
nature
c'est crac je pense de son côté c'est
que la garde présidentielle et la police
qui était à la disposition de bokassa
vont se débander et que par conséquent
l'armée à elle seule ne soient pas
susceptibles d'assurer toutes les
missions de maintien de l'ordre
je pense personnellement qu'il y a eu
suffisamment de massacres et de troubles
à bangui
pour que il nous essayons de faire tout
ce qui est en notre possible pour qu'il
n'y en avait pas d'autres qu'il faut
savoir pour essayer de bien comprendre
la position française c'est qu'il ya
là-bas des enjeux économiques et
financiers très importants avec entre
autres vous savez la spoliation des
mines d'uranium de centrafrique
l'ex oubangui chari c'est ainsi que l'on
appelait autrefois la république
centrafricaine est fondamentalement un
pays sous-développé qui n'a que peu
bénéficié de l'exploitation de ces
matières premières le revenu moyen par
habitant est de l'ordre de 100 francs
par mois
l'agriculture fournit plus de la moitié
de la valeur totale des exportations
essentiellement café coton et tabac la
forêt une des plus riches du monde
et quant à elles peu exploité en raison
des difficultés de transport restent
donc les richesses minières se sont
elles qui explique sans doute en grande
partie l'indulgence des pays occidentaux
pour le régime de jean bedel bokassa
les gisements d'uranium d'abord
découvert à bas coût dans le sud du pays
qui ne sont pas actuellement exploités
deux raisons à cela
ils sont pauvres en teneur est située
dans une région difficilement
accessibles autres richesses les
diamants près de 270 mille carats par an
font de la république centrafricaine le
12e producteur mondial
l'emploi en lui-même portait pas grand
intérêt ces diamants qu'ils utilisaient
volontiers à des fins personnelles on
estime aujourd'hui que les chiffres de
production annuelle sont largement
inférieurs ou quantités réellement
extraite
jean françois kahn de la chute de
bokassa encore un tyran moins étonnante
années 70 et voulons cette année 79
aurait été si j'ose dire aux tirs ont un
peu ce que l'ouragan david a été aux
antilles il suffit de récapituler
d'abord paul potts à commencer par paul
top ne l'oublions pas ils avaient
massacré la moitié de sa population on
pouvait penser qu'ils seraient
tranquilles avec l'autre balayés vous me
direz que une armée étrangère à
contribuer à lever les iem enfin s'il y
avait eu quelqu'un qui avait envie de le
soutenir cette invasion n'aurait pas été
possible et pour le cambodge le shah
d'iran une armée considérable une police
privée une police politique omniprésente
des moyens financiers énormes balayé lui
aussi plus de shah d'iran amin dada amin
dada la terreur considéré comme un sport
des prisonniers qu'on donnait à manger
aux crocodiles des soutiens de l'union
soviétique aussi bien que des pays
arabes plus d'un mille dada ou est il
aujourd'hui un fuyard un exclu somoza
somoza il possédait un tiers de son pays
il avait une garde privée personnelle il
n'hésitait pas bombarder sa propre
capitale pour venir à bout des opposants
pouvaient penser que vous au moins lui
il était bien à sa place avec de tels
moyens plus de somoza balayé à son tour
le président masia terminée
il avait contraint à l'exil un tiers de
sa population
ils avaient massacré 90% de son propre
parlement et ou s'il avait des aides
dans certains pays on pouvait penser que
lui au moins il avait rien a craint plus
de macias lui aussi aujourd'hui c'est un
exilé et enfin bokassa renversé par qui
par un rapport moral d'amnesty
international les philosophes de
certaines mères sont venus à bout du
prince
alors bien sûr certains des remplaçants
rivalisent d'horreur avec ceux qui l'ont
renversé c'est le cas de l'iran mais
quand même il faut dire une chose c'est
peut-être une banalité mais il faut le
répéter tous ces gens tous ces gens
parce qu'il contrôlait tout parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de syndicats pour les
embêter parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'opposants pour les critiquer parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de de presse pour
contester leur décision se croyait fort
très fort
eh bien ils étaient très faibles car je
vous le rappelle en 79
aucune démocratie parlementaire ne s'est
écroulé voilà ce qu'a à 8h15 nous
pouvions dire sur cette affaire
centrafricaine en vous rappelant
l'information qui est tombé en tout
début de journal à savoir l'arrivée de
l'ex-empereur bokassa donc à evreux
visiblement je vous le disais le souhait
du gouvernement français de ne pas le
garder trop longtemps
deuxième gros titres une affaire
inquiétante baignée par le contexte de
la sortie en france du syndrome chinois
c'est une grave accusation portée et par
la cgt et par la cfdt je la résume des
pièces utilisées pour la construction
des centrales nucléaires présenterait de
nombreuses fissures et de graves défauts
de fabrication
jean claude renaud a recueilli l'avis de
l'accusateur et l'accusé du syndicat et
du ministre et philippe dumez nous
disent qu'il faut en penser elles
centrale bwr sont en fait l'appellation
de tous les réacteurs nucléaires que
l'on construit actuellement en france
excepté celui de craie smallville six
réacteurs de ce type à fessenheim et
abusait fonctionne déjà
le réacteur proprement dit est construit
sous licence américaine et ils utilisent
de l'uranium légèrement enrichi à 3 %
une cuve en acier ordinaire recouverte
d'acier inoxydable d'une épaisseur de
plus de 20 cm protège le coeur où
s'effectue la réaction nucléaire
un circuit d'eau que l'on appelle
primaire passent à travers le coeur du
réacteur et transmet l'énergie thermique
ainsi collecté un deuxième circuit par
l'intermédiaire d'un échangeur de
chaleur
c'est ce 12e circuit qui alimente en
vapeur l'alternateur qui produit
l'électricité les fissures qui ont été
repérés au niveau de la cuve inquiète
beaucoup les syndicats dans la mesure où
l'on prévoit la mise en route ou le
fonctionnement de 28 réacteurs de ce
type dès l'année prochaine
là où les choses sont graves c'est que
jusqu'à présent ont considéré que parmi
les accidents possibles pour lesquels on
prenait les mesures de sécurité il y en
avait un qui était exclu c'était la
rupture de la cuve direct or l'existence
de ces défauts montre qu'une telle
rupture est possible et c'est pour
rendre compte particulièrement grave
pour les travailleurs et pour la
population et pour cent n'a pas prévu de
parade et pour ça il n'y a pas de parade
en quelle centrale sont touchés par ce
problème est que des pratiquement ce
dont nous avons la certitude c'est que
toutes les nouvelles centrales celles
qui doivent être installés dans les
semaines qui viennent
dampierre gravelines tricastin mais
également toutes celles qui sont en
construction pour le programme
pwr sent concerné et celles qui sont en
fonctionnement
alors nous ne sommes pas certain mais
comme elles sont construits sur le même
modèle il est possible qu'elle soit
affectée par ces mêmes défauts en tout
cas il faut le vérifier de toute urgence
alors vous adresser au ministre de
l'industrie en région pour lui demander
quoi nous lui demandons
qu'est ce qu'il a l'intention de décider
en ce qui concerne centrales en service
dont il faut contrôler qu'elle risque
pas d'avoir ce type d'accident pour les
centrales qui doivent être mises en
fonctionnement
évidemment ce qu'il a l'intention de
faire et il nous semble à nous que pour
des raisons de sécurité il n'est pas
pensable que l'on mette en route des
machines en quelque sorte qu'ils sont
susceptibles de provoquer des accidents
alors que par le passé ceux ci étaient
exclues c'est au niveau de la jonction
entre la puye au tri du circuit primaire
et la cuve du réacteur que des fissures
ont été décelés cette découverte a été
faite lors de contrôles de ce matériel
en cours de finition et avant son
transfert pour une centrale ces fissures
ne sont pas très importantes
puisqu'elles font 10 mm de long et 6 mm
de profondeur à un endroit où la plaque
d'acier fait plus de 20 cm d'épaisseur
tout le problème actuellement est de
savoir comment ces fissures vont
vieillir
si les études montrent qu'il peut y
avoir un risque d'agrandissement il
faudra arrêter tous les réacteurs en
fonctionnement
car le danger d'une fuite radioactive ne
serait pas exclue pourtant ni l'edf ni
au gouvernement on ne pense que ces
petites fissures puisse avoir une grosse
importance
les services de sécurité fonctionne
puisque le phénomène n'est pas connue
d'aujourd'hui il est connu déjà depuis
pas mal de temps
il est observé avec toute la vigilance
nécessaire je peux donc vous garantir
que toute la vigilance nécessaire sera
porté par les services de sécurité
donc ces figures existent alors était il
ya des défauts superficiel comme
l'indiqué et df c'est un problème de
métallurgie choix et qu'il n'est pas
étonnant puisque le problème n'est pas
nouveau que les français l'apprennent
par la voix d'une conférence de presse
syndicale a coûté les syndicats ont
décidé de faire une conférence de presse
sur ce sujet mais moi je n'ai pas
attendu les conférences de presse pour
que les services de sûreté fassent leur
travail et hors dom les inspections
nécessaires quel type d'inspection et
pour quel centrales celles qui sont en
fonctionnement celles qui sont en
construction
il ya des inspections courante et
périodiques qui sont fait non seulement
sur scène où cela a été observée mais
sur toutes les centrales pour être sûr
que l'on remet bien au courant de tout
ce qui se passe et dans ces conditions
la conférence de presse d'andré giro sur
l'aide à l'industrie est passé quelque
peu inaperçu le ministre a annoncé que
l'état allait multiplier les contrats de
développement à petites entreprises il a
également fait le point sur la recherche
pétrolière à titre d'exemple la
compagnie total vient d'obtenir un
permis de recherche sur le nord et le
pas de calais l'aisne et la somme
recherche de gaz plutôt que d'huile et
puis pour terminer avec les affaires
économiques sachez que l'or a poursuivi
aujourd'hui son recul le lingot avait
perdu à paris plus de 13 100 francs hier
il a encore baissé de la moitié à
d'après-midi - 650 francs les rendez
vous sociaux de matignon première
invitée comme souvent à l'habitude andré
bergeron le leader de force ouvrière
andré bergeron quilles devant raymond
barre a sorti de sa poche une liste de
cinq questions que nous détaille l'andra
première question d'andré bergeron la
politique contractuelle
réponse de monsieur bart pas blocage des
salaires dans le secteur privé maintien
du pouvoir d'achat dans le secteur
public
deuxième question les bas salaires
monsieur bart confirme l'augmentation du
smic en décembre il incitera le patronat
à négocier sur les ressources minimal
garanti par brf
troisièmement le temps de travail le
gouvernement souhaite un accord sur
l'aménagement du temps de 6 janvier
il prendra bientôt des mesures pour
réguler de 48 à 46 heures la durée du
travail dans certaines branches
quatrième point la cinquième semaine
le gouvernement ne prendra pas
d'orientation mais il ne s'opposera pas
à ces négociations dans les entreprises
qui obtiennent de bons résultats
économiques
dernière question d'andré bergeron il
est réélu dimanche qu'aucun projet de
loi n'était actuellement en cours de
préparation et je crois pouvoir vous
dire qu'aucune décision ne sera prise
sans qu'il y ait nous at on dit un
accord de toutes les parties comme y
aura au moins une des parties qui ne
sera pas d'accord c'est à dire les
syndicats d'employés on peut donc
espérer que cette affaire ne n'est pas
pour demain heureusement mais alors que
dans l'ensemble pour la fin 1979 et
début 80 vous pensez qu'une politique
contractuelle est possible oui et nous
ferons tout pour l'imposer
ça n'est jamais facile ça n'a jamais été
facile mais je crois que de ce point de
vue encore une fois on nous a donné des
assurances pour 1981 je parle des grands
contrats qui arriveront à échéance à la
fin de cette année s'est satisfait cette
rencontre vous savez c'est jamais en
noir et blanc il ya toujours des points
de difficulté
il y en a d'autres qui sont plus
favorables sur la cinquième semaine de
congés par exemple nous avons pour la
première fois obtenu de monsieur raymond
barre l'assurance que le gouvernement ne
s'opposerait pas à la signature
d'accords instituant la cinquième
semaine de congés payés
pour le reste je vous répète ce que j'ai
dit au meeting de rentrée chèque ça vous
intrigue la cinquième semaine c'est pour
bientôt
pour tout le monde naturellement pour
noël 80 nos demandes bombay pas
davantage c'est pour bientôt
la semaine prochaine les voudraient mon
bar avec la fen puis la cfdt ce la
semaine suivante la cgt le gouvernement
fera le point rose à un taux de l'ami
octobre plusieurs milliers de
manifestants ce matin devant le
ministère du travail pour protester
contre le risque d' ouverture des
magasins le dimanche
le dimanche est sacré disaient les
banderoles le dimanche c'est pour mon
mari et pour nos enfants
robert boulin qui a reçu une délégation
syndicale a confirmé que le gouvernement
n'avait pas l'intention de déposer un
projet de loi en la matière lors de la
prochaine session
la mort de marcel le coeur le fondateur
de la fédération des artisans du
bâtiment il avait 81 ans est l'un des
hommes qui je crois a le plus contribué
à modifier le visage de l'artisanat
france au sortir de la guerre
le grand rabbin kaplan alizés ce matin
ce sera l'invité de notre lettre ouverte
à l'an 2000 après demain à l'heure du
déjeuner après l'assassinât à hyères de
pierre goldman tué par neuf balles de
revolver l'indignation est quasi
générale
le parti socialiste la cfdt le mrap la
ligue communiste révolutionnaire
jean paul sartre et pratiquement tous
nos confrères condamne ce crime odieux
cet après midi sur les lieux mêmes où
étais tu es cas goldman et partis de
gauche et d'extrême gauche
organiser une manifestation au départ de
la manifestation émotions et dignité
visible sur tous les visages
à l'appel de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire à l'incriminer tela de
l'organisation communiste des
travailleurs du psu du comité communiste
pour l'autogestion vu que l'équipe
nationale bat romain 1er mai les
manifestants environ 2000 s'étaient
réunis place de l'abbé georges enough
dans le xiiie arrondissement parisien
il empruntait ensuite la rue des
peupliers vers 19 heures quelques
incidents se sont produits entre
policiers et manifestants
en haut du boulevard blanqui il ya
quelques minutes on apprenait que des
éléments incontrôlés avaient jeté des
pierres sur les forces de l'ordre qui
ont riposté à l'aide de gaz lacrymogènes
à l'heure actuelle le gros de la
manifestation stationnent toujours place
denfert rochereau
le commissaire marcel leclère nouveau
chef de la brigade criminelle il
remplace le commissaire ottavioli qui
occupait ce poste depuis cinq ans
maintenant concorde les invendus vont
voler c'est maintenant officiel les
trois concorde qui attendait un acheteur
à toulouse vont être alloués à air
france
l'exploitation du supersonique
franco-britannique et homps et
déficitaires air france a transporté
avec cet avion
plus de deux cent mille passagers un
taux d'occupation de 60 % actuellement
concorde est en france
déficitaire je puis vous assurer qu air
france que le gouvernement français font
tout pour avoir une meilleure
rentabilité de lit y est il y as
développement des coefficients de
remplissage et nous souhaitons qu'ils
aient développement de la cadence sur
certaines lignes en particulier sur la
ligne nord atlantique
c'est parti depuis hier on peut vraiment
considérer que le coup d'envoi de la
campagne électorale américaine a été
donnée hier en deux temps ce d'abord
protection officielle par la police
edward kennedy protection décidées par
jimmy carter lui même et puis
parallèlement un tout autre niveau les
attaques contre hamilton jordan le
secrétaire général de la maison blanche
vous allez voir dans quelles conditions
cela se passait dans les journaux
télévisés de la cie billet si hier soir
et c'est un sénateur démocrate dont du
même parti que jimmy carter qui dit à
porter une accusation grave j'ai vu les
conseillers de la maison blanche qui
sont arrivés accompagnés de jeunes
filles bien de ses conseillers m'a même
dit que je pouvais prendre n'importe
laquelle de ses filles sauf une sauf une
qui était réservé à hamilton jordan le
plus proche conseiller du président
carter
il était presque sorti comme sorties
d'un zoo il parlait de drogue et de
filles et à mon avis et la relaxation
dont il faisait preuve venez à mon
humble avis encore une fois carnet de la
drogue et des filles hockey huit ans
dans une bulle de plastique
david c'est ce petit garçon dont nous
avons souvent parlé il est né avec plat
avec un organisme sans aucun élément de
défense naturelle un petit rhume serait
pour lui fatale
david vit donc depuis huit ans c'était
son anniversaire aujourd'hui chez lui
dans une bulle stérile de trois pièces à
trice martin a réussi un nouveau record
du monde ce petit garçon de 15 ans a
battu aujourd'hui son propre record du
monde en ski nautique au cours de la
deuxième journée des championnats du
monde qui se déroule à toronto au canada
et puis des images maintenant de la
victoire de nancy hier à quitter une
ville en irlande
vous savez que les canaris ont gagné 1
but à 0 but marqué par gilles rampillon
j'ajouterai que patrick de payet ne
courra plus dans l'écurie ligier
cette décision a été prise d'un commun
accord et on ne connaît pas encore
l'endroit où courra la saison prochaine
patrick de payet et qui va le remplacer
chedli j'ai des nouvelles de la presse
maintenant qu'après les suppléments
dominicaux du monde et du figaro
dimanche le journal du dimanche à son
tour publie cette semaine un supplément
tout en couleurs le septième jour et
puis si vous êtes de ceux qui lisent la
vie ou jour de france sachez qu'une
grève aux imprimeries langue empêche
pour l'instant la parution cette semaine
de ses journaux la météo maintenant
aujourd'hui le temps vous avez pu le
remarquer et et à la pluie à l'exception
quand même de quelques régions notamment
sur les ardennes les vosges le jura et
puis la région parisienne ce matin
demain bien le temps sera frais sur
l'ensemble du pays en même des gelées
blanches dans les régions de l'intérieur
les éclaircies seront généralement
prédominante avec cependant des averses
près de la manche
le mistral et la tramontane persisteront
sur les régions méditerranéennes
avant de vous donner les avons rendez
vous avec
informations sur antenne 2 je vous
rappellerai cette information que je
vous donnais en tout début de journal
l'ex-empereur bokassa atterri tout à
l'heure à evreux à 19h50 à la base
militaire il soit dit visiblement
rejoindre son épouse l'ex impératrice
catherine mais le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas sa présence il y a un petit
problème diplomatique nous avons
téléphoné car on s'est aperçu en effet
que je l'ex-empereur posséder les deux
nationalités la nationalité
centrafricaine et la nationalité
française
donc je vous rappelle il semble que le
parlement ne souhaite pas beaucoup la
présence de bokassa en france donc ses
rendez vous d'information avec antonio
d'abord ce soir à 22h45 paul amar demain
samedi ennemi sera présentée par jean
claude mongeau l'émission sera consacré
à l'habitat et au vie nouvelle et puis à
20h vous retrouverez cette même place
daniel bilalian faut quand même terminé
ce journal avec des images émouvantes et
qui peuvent parfois dire que j'ai tant
que prêter à sourire s'agit de ce
service funéraire pour l'asnl and 16
jours après la mort du pandas offerts
par les chinois les japonais continuent
de pleurer leurs ours blancs de
l'himalaya plus de 3000 d'entre eux ont
déposé aujourd'hui devant son mémorial
des chrysanthèmes et chanter adieu lan
man un chant composé pour la
circonstance
voilà je vous laisse sur ces images
passées tout de même une bonne fin de
semaine
votre rêve désolant enfin